[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, everybody. Welcome
to the Data Science Hangout.
If we haven't met before,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I'm the host of
our Hangout here,
and I lead customer
marketing at Posit.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you are watching this
on YouTube at some point in the
future and you want
to join us live,
there'll be a link
in the details below,
where you can add
it to your calendar.
At the Hangouts,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody. So we love
to hear from everyone, no matter
your years of experience,
your titles, your industry,
or the languages that
you work in, too.
It's totally OK to just
listen in here as well.
I know sometimes people
will be out for a walk.
Maybe you're on your lunch break,
or it's later in your day.
And there's always
three ways, though,
that you could jump in and
ask questions or provide your own perspective.
So one, you could jump in
by raising your hand here on Zoom,
and I'll be on the lookout.
Two, you can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And if it's something you
want me to read instead,
just put a little
star next to it.
And then three, we
also have a Slido link,
which I'm sure Curtis or
someone from the team will
share in just a second here,
where you can ask
questions anonymously, too.
But with all that,
thank you for spending your
Thursday with us. I'm so
excited to introduce my
colleague and co-host for
today, Julia Silge.
Julia is a software engineer
here at Posit. And Julia,
I'd love to have you introduce yourself
and share a little bit about your role,
maybe something you like
to do outside of work, too.
- Great.
Yeah. Hello, everyone.
I'm so glad to be here.
My name is Julia, and I
have worked at Posit for--
going on four years now. And
I was first hired to--
so I work on one of
the open-source teams,
who focuses on
open-source software, and
mostly are.
When I first came
to then RStudio,
I was on the tidymodels team.
And I was on the tidymodels
team for 2 and halfish years,
something like that. And
it was a really exciting
time to work on the tidymodels
team because it was just
getting to a point where it
really was mature enough to be
used for people's real
machine learning and
modeling workflow.
So that was really exciting.
From when I was
hired, originally,
one of the things that
was on the table for
something I would work with would
be to work on the really
applied and practical problems of
deployment of what you need to
do with a model after you have
trained it. And so after being
on the tidymodels team for
about a year, I started digging
into that. And then maybe about
a year after that, I
transitioned to really working on that
fullish time.
Most of my emphasis going to
those kinds of deployment kinds of things.
And we also hired someone to--
from the beginning,
the plan was that, will
that was always to make that something
that worked for R and Python,
because the technologies
that people use to deploy
models are really not very
specific to what language you
use to train them in.
And so we really saw this
as an opportunity to help people have
choices and have a unified
approach at the end.
So the MLOps project
is one that is
bilingual. That is
R and Python. So
we do just that, do both
of that. So if you have ever
used something like pins,
me and my team work on
that for R and Python.
The particular package
that is focused on
model deployment is vetiver.
And then there are other kind
of handful of things that
are a little lower level, that
are behind some of these things, that
we take responsibility
for and maintain.
Most of the people who work
on open-source software,
I do a mix of
writing actual code and
then writing documentation, and
making materials so that people can
know how to use our tools.
So that's a little bit about
me and what I do here and
the kind of things that I focus on.
- Awesome.
And what about something you
like to do outside of work?
- Yes.
So I
would say that my--
I don't have something like really
exciting for this list. It's like
reading books,
watching TV shows,
doing things with my family.
Nothing really unusual
or out of the ordinary.
I almost pains me to
admit this. But since the
disintegration of Twitter,
I have read twice as many books
this year as I did last year.
- That's great. Yeah.
- It's good. But I
always maintained--
I was like, oh, no,
it doesn't affect me.
It's not taking up
that much of my time.
But I literally have read
twice as many books this year,
as I did last year. And I
read a couple just now that were
very spooky
Halloween-appropriate.
One is a really warm,
sweet, ghost romance. It's called
The Dead
Romantics. Lovely.
And then one is
gothy sci-fi
thing. It's called
Gideon the
Ninth, and it was also
a delight, although more gory.
Not too much. I can't
handle a lot but
a little more grim.
- I love that.
We can bring a little Halloween
theme into this week, too.
- Yeah. It's fantastic.
- Maurice had a great call-out
to your YouTube channel as well,
and I thought it might be nice to
just ask a little bit about that first.
What led you to start
creating some of those videos?
And can you tell us a
little bit about them?
- Sure.
I think I started at
first as an experiment.
So I've done blogging for
a long time, and my initial
motivation for blogging
was that I was actually
transitioning into data science as
a career. This is maybe 10-ish,
eightish years ago, and I was
trying to make a career
transition before--
my academic background
is physics and astronomy.
And I had been doing--
I was in research
for a long time.
Then I worked at
an EdTech startup
and EdTech kind of company.
And I was transitioning into
data science. And I thought,
OK, I have this weird
background.
How are people going to know that
I can do this job at all?
And so vloggin was part of me,
trying to have this idea of a
portfolio to be able to--
for my own career growth thing.
But it really led to so much
that was good in my life and career.
And when I came here
to work at, then, RStudio,
tidymodels was really
at a point where--
it was really at
a point where--
thing to deal with is, how do we
show people how to use this? How do we
demonstrate it? So I did it
as an experiment to be like,
is this something that
would be helpful to people?
It's interesting.
I would always rather read
something than watch a video
about something personally. I'm like,
oh my gosh, just let me
read it. Why is
everything a video now?
I'm in my mid-40s, so you know.
But
at the same time, there were
times when I would watch
videos. And I was like, oh, I didn't
know you could do that, or like, oh,
I never saw someone do that
in the way they actually were
writing code or the way
they used their IDE or something
like that. And so,
I see the benefits
of both video
for communication and
teaching and all that, and
written.
And written is certainly
my first choice.
And so you'll notice
all my screencasts,
I pop up a quick blog post.
I don't put a ton of energy
into it, but I always--
there's always a place
you can go to see it.
I also do that partly
because I have had people
talk to me about the
accessibility issues around
video for communication. And if
you have something that is text that's HTML
on a website that's
much more accessible to
people who need to use
screen readers or have--
so I always try to do both.
I always try to do both.
So at the beginning, I was
like, let's do an experiment. Let's see.
And I think it really helped
people see tidymodels as
something that was like, oh, I
can try that. Let me do that.
Let me do that.
And so that would be what went
into the start of it. And then
certainly, as I've moved--
depending on the balance of my time
in every given month, I don't always--
my goal is to do two a month,
but I don't always
hit two a month.
-
I really like having both
the video and blog format too
because if you get
stuck in either one,
you go to the other
and unblocks you.
- Yeah.
- I see Ben. You had a
question in the Zoom chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah.
Hey, Julia. I'm curious,
you've obviously been on
long term to value projects--
longer term--
so you're not able to see--
the benchmark is
just really high.
And I have a couple that
I'm working on as well
for an internal solution.
And it's hard to maintain
the excitement, also, to create
that vision for the end
goal and also to vet it out.
So I have five
different questions built into this.
- OK. Let's see if I
can remember them all.
Let's do them one at a time.
- So the idea is--
the main one is,
how do you maintain
excitement and enthusiasm but
also maintain a clear scope
over a long term
to value project?
- Yeah.
So this
is a great question.
I think that the number 1
thing is
to--
I know you all have seen
these kind of pictures.
You can think about waterfall
versus MVP.
And you've seen those pictures
of making a bike or something.
And it's like, what do you do
make first? Do you make a wheel?
And you're like, I made
a wheel. Here, it's ready.
And then you make the seat.
Here's a seat. Or do you like,
is the first thing that you
make a really simple skateboard
thing that someone can use
to get somewhere and then you
change and change?
So I think
it is so important
to build in such a way
that at any given point,
there's something that
you can show and
say, here is the idea of
what it's going to be.
And I'm going to improve it
in this way and this way,
and then improve it in ways.
And it is true that
sometimes this means--
it can take longer to get
to the eventual thing,
like the perfect bike
thing that you have.
It is I think so important
for buy in from stakeholders,
and it's so important for
people seeing you as someone
who ships and
who gets things done.
And it provides something
useful that you get something
useful as early as possible,
even if it is not the
eventual way you're
going to do it.
I think adopting
that kind of mindset,
it makes a huge difference
in how collaborative people think
you are and how responsive
people think you are,
like your
organization, how your
position with an organization, if
you can break things down.
I mean, there's tons of books
and blog posts about this.
I'm not saying anything crazy or
new but even for something statistical.
Can I do--
can I give someone
something that is dead simple
now? And then can I iterate,
iterate, iterate.
Like if you were talking
about a machine learning context,
it's like can I do something
that I almost even didn't have
to train or that doesn't
use machine learning,
like as an initial like here.
It's going to look like this.
It's going to be this API.
And right now,
what's serving it is
something like so
dumb, like so simple.
And then you do a model
that you can train in a
literally 10 minutes and then you
do that and then you try to
improve it rather than to
get to something great.
I think that that does
have to be balanced with
how much--
just time it takes
to do projects.
But I think within the scope
of whatever kind of project you're doing,
if you can really think about not
trying to build it up in pieces
so that the individual
pieces, like that
they're as useful as
early as possible,
even if that means
you build it simpler.
So I think that
is important. And
that really helps
the teams I've been on in
that like maintaining
motivation.
Because if people are actually
using even the very early
versions of what you're doing,
you get feedback on it.
you learn about what--
you learn earlier what people
are actually looking for.
And that--
versus that very siloed
feeling of like, well,
I'm just going to grind away for
a very long time on this big project.
But instead of that feeling,
like what about this?
What about this? Like
getting feedback.
I think, for teams I
have worked on has been very
motivating, very motivating.
- And can I ask that next one, Rachel?
- Go for it. Yeah. Go for it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- I love--
I love that explanation
too, though Julia.
-
So the ideas that come
about obviously you're not limiting
yourself to just like to ideas
that you've had over the last
six or seven years.
So how do you vet the
ideas that you're coming up with and
that you're seeing with
yourself and also with your
team to make sure that they're
valid and they're worth
creating a vision around?
- That's a great question.
So you're asking if--
OK. Yeah. So
I am also
a pretty big fan of
like small experiments, small
experiments and hypotheses. And this
is related
to the thing that we
were just talking about
deciding--
like getting to something--
like demo
level, getting to something--
there's these minimum
viable project.
These are the kind of words--
getting to something
as early as possible.
Like literally sometimes
timeboxing something to one
afternoon, one hour, even.
Like what can I get in one
hour? And can I show this to
someone and get feedback on it
and see what resonates about it
and what doesn't?
So that I think
is like one of the
biggest
tools I've used to
evaluate ideas or evaluate hypotheses.
Like if we try
something, is it like--
does it resonate? Does
someone want to see more?
Does someone want to--
have changes they want to
suggest it? Or are people like--
I don't know.
I am really biased towards
ship
early and experiment
and don't have--
and I just mean that you'd--
like for me,
it's like I have to have
an attitude of like holding these
things with a very light
hand that I'm like--
I'm not super invested
in this or this, like
I just want to know. What
do you think? What do you think?
Like that type of thing.
So on the positive like example
of this, that is how Vetiver
happened actually.
So
I think--
I was like, it's like MLOps
as a tool, feels so or--
as a field or idea feels like
so big, a little hype-driven and what,
oh, we can't--
we say, we as Posits,
it's like, can we
play in that space? Is
that reasonable for us?
There are whole startups that
that's nothing what they do.
And like I had a
hypothesis, I was like,
I think the pieces are
here in open source.
And people are already kind
of bailing wire these things
together themselves,
m if they're not like buying
into a startup product MLOps thing.
What if we made like an
open source thing that really used
components, pieces
that are already there?
And so the initial version that
I like showed someone was like,
I think we have most
of what we need,
and we just need to make
like the user experience nice for
this particular model base
use case. And so that was--
like the initial--
I did actually--
the initial thing I made was
actually much more Shiny-like
and ended up being,
in terms of what it
looked, like a server, like
all this kind of thing.
And I ended up--
I ended up there ended up being
a fairly big shift of like, oh,
OK. No, no, no. We're not going
to do it that way. We're going to
instead do like
code generation,
a fair amount of code
generation behind the scene--
so I shifted.
But there were things about
the initial version I showed people
that resonated. They were
like, OK, they want to do X.
And then there were
things about it.
They were like, I don't know.
Like that's not making sense
to me or like that seems too
complicated. Like I think
I should be simpler.
And so there were things about
it that helped me iterate
towards something.
And then we iterate, iterate,
and keep going forward and land
on something that hopefully fits pretty
well. So I think that--
I probably
lean
less,
I would say, on my own
opinions or tastes unlike,
I am sure this is right.
And I tend to--
I tend to lean more on, let
me like show things to people, let
me do even user interviews,
like let me like
use some of those tools to
figure out how things
need to happen.
- Yeah.
I see there's a
little conversation in the chat
happening about this too.
And we can definitely jump
on to other topics too.
But I wanted to make
sure while that conversation is happening,
we dive into.
George, do you want to add
your follow on question?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I guess I've had the
experience where people really don't want
to see those
intermediate steps that
just want that final thing,
especially to your point about
even in cases where
it's a statistical
model or something that
you're needing to deliver. Sometimes,
delivering a simple
thing is good enough.
I've had the experience
where it's just not.
And I think it's because
of perception of stability or
maybe just the culture.
- Yeah.
- And so I don't know if
you've ever come across that. But it's like,
it's basically like you have to
sell the whole thing or else it
dies. And I don't know if
you ever had that experience
and how you've overcome that.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
this experience where
someone
doesn't view it as important
to give feedback on an
intermediate thing or to look
at an intermediate thing or to
start integrating
something that
is less complete or less
mature or less finished
into maybe the system
that you're going for.
So if it is something--
if it is really something
that you're like,
I need--
I need feedback on these
intermediate steps in order to
get where I need to go,
it can be helpful to
explain
why.
Like explain why we want to
build things
with an iterative improvement.
If you're talking to a
software engineer colleague,
they probably resonate
with this idea.
Because it's so common
in software engineering,
this idea of we do
something small, then we improve it.
Like we don't do something--
we don't do something huge
and massive all at once.
Like we know that's
more prone to errors.
It's more prone to not
getting where you want to be.
So you can--
so I have had luck with
software engineer colleagues in
explaining this is like
what you do but for data
work. So I need you to--
I need
us to take these steps so that
we end up in a better place in
the long run. I think that
it might be interesting, George, to--
if you're having this problem
more with say like a business
stakeholder, like
less with an engineer,
an engineering stakeholder in your
day to work and more like
a business stakeholder.
And
I have had more challenges
in those situations in trying to--
and trying to get
those kinds of answers.
So sometimes, I have been
in a situation where just share
and
partly, and as a like,
here's where it is. And the
next steps are X next week.
Here's where it is and next
steps are Y. If I do need
feedback, if I do need--
I
need something back
the other direction,
it can be more challenging
with business stakeholders
to understand that.
But
when I have had
success with that,
overcoming that
kind of obstacle,
it has been through
a fairly specific
request or like a
fairly specific--
I have a--
I have a prototype of
the statistical
results. It's not--
it's in its final version but
I need to ask you these questions
about it. And if either set
a meeting or if it's async like
a question A, question
B, question C.
And then when I've
had success, it's been--
like I really clearly
understand why I need something.
It's like the goal is
this. To get to the goal,
I need to know which
of these things too.
But that can be a more--
because there's less
of a culture I think.
With engineers,
there's more of a
norm and expected culture around.
We do things iteratively
to get a better result.
But I have had more.
It has been more challenging there.
And then I think
connecting it to
what is the goal and saying
like this is what I need
has been how I have
had success in that.
But I have sometimes been in
a situation where just feel like,
am I just putting this
out into the void?
-
It's an interesting thought to
think about how we get other
people to think
iteratively as well.
But Husada,
I see you had a question a
bit earlier about tidymodels.
Do you want to jump in?
And I can read the question and
if you want to jump in and add
more context, feel free.
But the question was,
how are the state of Tidymodels
adaptations? Are there
enough adopters or users
to please the Tidymodels teams
metric or target?
Are there targets?
- Yeah. That's a
great question.
Much so,
I think that
it is--
so when I have been--
while I have worked on
open source projects,
adoption
is something that
open source teams watch,
that open source teams
pay attention to, and decide.
Well,
it's like one piece of data
we have to decide how to invest
and what to invest in. Like if
you're there,
are like two things we can
invest in our projects,
we invest in. How
do we prioritize them? One of
the things that goes into is
things like adoption.
It's not the only thing,
because sometimes that's
not the only reason to
invest in something.
Like I talk about this all
the time, all the time.
But you probably are familiar
with the idea of the data
science hierarchy of needs.
Monica Rogati wrote about this
in 2017 or 16 or something.
And at the bottom is like,
you're collecting data at all.
And then one up
is you're doing--
you're doing analytics,
things like dashboards.
One like a level up
from that is like--
is like statistical analysis,
like maybe things like a T-test
or maybe something like a linear model.
And above that, you're
using machine learning.
And at the top is like AI
kind of thing. And you can think
about that also in terms of, where
does model deployment go on
that? Like it's up pretty high.
Like people have to be using--
have to be having models.
They need to have models
that are deployed.
Like it's up pretty high
in that hierarchy of needs.
So that affects
adoption numbers.
Like something like Tidymodels
is never going to have the
adoption numbers of
something like Shiny.
Because they're at different
places in the data science
hierarchy of needs.
But at the same time,
like if you're thinking about
what should we invest in?
You want to make sure that
when people look at tooling or
a language or
a company's products or
something, that when people
look at it, they can see
that it can grow with them.
They can see that this is not
a tool that like maxes out.
Or if you do decide to do that,
you need to do it
very carefully.
Like when people
look at this tool,
they're going to understand
its scope is limited.
And they can't use
it beyond X level
of scale or maturity
or whatever.
So there's different reasons.
I would say that in
terms of adoption--
that
when we look at who
wants to come to conf and learn
about something or like who
if we look at-- like
who,
like internally, and our customers,
like how often are people
asking about a tool or wanting
like to know more about how to
do something. We
feel good about the investment
that has been made in Tidymodels.
Certainly, certainly,
when you think about--
if you were to go right now
to GitHub and like count up like
how many people or how
many things are using
Tidymodels versus something
else, which you might--
what would you compare it to?
Would you compare it to Carrot?
Would you compare it to
Scikit Learn? Like probably,
if you were to compare
those numbers, you'd be like, oh,
there's more projects that
use Carrot because Carrot's have
been around for like 15 more
years or something like that or
Scikit Learn, many
more projects,
for reasons that we understand.
But
so I think that if
you ask the question, like is
Posit happy about the
investment that has been made
in Tidymodels? I think
it really fits a need,
like a need that people have.
And so in that sense has
been really happy about the investment.
- Awesome. Julia, a question I wanted
to ask you is, I see a
lot of things on LinkedIn that
are like models are rarely
deployed or oh, teams spent
all this time developing something,
and it doesn't go anywhere.
Why does that happen?
- I think some of the
time that's appropriate.
Like that's normal and OK.
Because
one thing that's
different about
machine learning as a
practice compared to software
engineering as a practice is
you can pretty much always
get--
you can pretty much
always build something.
Like if you write out
a spec for something that's like,
we need to build X like
as a software engineer.
Let's write out a spec. Let's
do it.
Like you pretty much
always can do that.
Maybe it will take longer than you
think or more investment than you think,
but actually that's not true
when it comes to machine
learning. Because until
you start the process,
you don't necessarily know that
you can predict the thing that
you need to predict from
the stuff that you have--
you end up, may end up not
having appropriate data. You may end up--
it is not good enough.
Like the results you get are
not good enough to predict that
you think that you want to.
So machine learning
as a practice is
it's more iterative.
It's more exploratory.
We're not even talking
specifically about exploratory
data analysis. But as
a practice, it is more
exploratory than say, we're
going to build a feature.
We're going to build
a feature. And it is--
you know you can be
less certain ahead of time that
whatever model
you're trying to do
you can actually fit,
especially within
whatever is needed.
So I think that it
happens because--
that that's a big reason why
it happens that is the nature
of data science and nature
of machine learning.
There's a really great paper.
I'm going to see if
I can find it real
quick, that talks about this.
Yes. OK. I found it. It's
called operationalizing machine
learning. And I'll put the
link here, and it talks about--
it talks about this in
the context of machine learning,
especially and really
just says, this is why.
Like this is why is because
of the nature of this work.
So that's one big reason.
I think another reason is
that it often when people are
working on machine learning
projects in their org,
they're bumping up against the
maturity of where they've been
before, where their org has
been before. And so peoples
don't have as much of the
muscle memory and the skills
about how to do these
things, how to deploy them.
So that's I think--
so the biggest--
I think big reason is like,
it is the nature of
machine learning as work.
The next piece is that
often when people are doing these
things, it's new to
their org or newer--
they're
exercising new skills.
And the other thing I think
that really contributes to this is
you almost always are ending
up collaborating across
functions. So most typically,
like you are needing--
if you're a more
statistical person,
you are now needing to
collaborate with someone who is
a more ops-y person. And
people work in different ways. Teams
don't sit together. Like
people end up with--
oh, that will never work.
Like that will never
work because of X.
And what can both sides do
to actually make something work if
it needs to happen.
So I think those are the real
reasons why this kind of thing happens.
- Yeah. Thank you.
I see, Patrick,
you had asked a question that
I think follows along to this
nicely. If you want
to jump in here too.
- Thanks, Rachel. And Julia, hi.
It's good to see you. Yeah.
This is very much what you
were just talking about and
references back to the data
science hierarchy of needs piece too.
So I'm just wondering what
advice would you give to a team
or an organization who's
struggling to go from, OK,
we have a model and
it fits well enough.
And it's doing what we want
it to do to having a model in
production that we're using
regularly and that we depend
on. That it feels like
a very big change to me
psychologically for the team or
the organization to go from.
Yes, we can do this to--
yes, we are relying
on this thing.
And it is in production
and it's important to us.
So what advice do you have for
people who are struggling to make that step?
- Yeah. Yeah. So I think
one thing is to acknowledge,
to understand that you as a
team or some part of the team
is going to need to
gain some new skills,
is going to need to learn how
to do some new things and to
try to make space
and understand that that
kind of change is coming and
is needed. So this is, for example,
like maybe it's important for someone
on your team to start in
learning
what does our org need?
If I were to deploy a model,
like what is going
to work for our org?
So this is now working
with maybe people who are DevOps-y,
maybe people who are sit-in IT.
So what are the new
skills we need to add?
So that's one thing is to
acknowledge that if you have
been very statistically focused
and it's time to deploy a
model, how can we make space
for some proportion of our team
to gain some of those skills?
I think also to not be afraid
of some of those tools and
skills and to
understand that
like that's how you
scale the impact of your work.
So for example, like to learn
about Docker, like
to learn about--
how do things work in your
org? If your org has a
certain Cloud platform, that
you all use, like to start--
to not so much be like,
OK, yes, we're the data people.
We work in this environment. But to
start to push again, like to find--
how do I go? How do I
then take that next step?
Also, I think doing things in
as small of way as possible.
So like you can--
if you're going to deploy
some kind of a model as
an API.
So like, it doesn't have to
the first time you do it be the
huge scalable,
can go to infinity kind of
API. Like you can first do
API at all. And then you show
like a software engineer
or DevOps-y kind of coworker,
like look, look. If we serve
this in this way, then you can
get predictions
back in this way.
And then have a discussion about how
can we start to scale that up.
So I think the first thing
is to think about the skills
that people need someone
needs to gain a little bit.
The second thing
is to think about
infrastructure and like
the tools you use now,
how are they different from
the tools that are being there.
Like what can you learn about
your internal specifics?
And then also going back
to that like iterative,
like do something as small as
possible to show and be like,
OK, how can we make--
take that next step.
- Got it. Thank you very much,
Julia. I appreciate that.
And thank you for building all
the tools that make that stuff
possible and easier.
And yes, fear of Docker sounds
like a great horror movie.
[LAUGHS]
- I know. I know. I know.
- I also--
I just shared in the chat
too if it's helpful for anyone,
especially with the
conversation right now.
Yesterday, Simon Couch from
our team led a demo using
Tidymodels and Posit Team.
And so it's a nice
walk through as well.
I just put that
link in the chat.
- That looks so great.
I'm really excited Simon
was able to do that.
- Yeah. It was really fun.
There are a lot of people
there too, which was great.
An anonymous question
that came in was,
if only or--
what is this?
If only there was a good
way to share these data science endpoints,
do you have any advice on
deploying and managing these
kinds of outputs?
- Yeah. So I think that
it is really important to find
an easy way to
do this in a--
like be able to have an MVP,
to be able to have a demo,
and then you can work
from there. So if you--
for those of you who are
customers or having trying to
make a argument around it,
like that is exactly
what Connect does.
Like Connect is a way that you
as a data scientist can deploy something
with one function,
with one button click.
Like it really lets you have a playground.
And then depending on the--
it really reduces the barrier
to that first like, ah,
I am serving an API.
Like here it is.
If you are in a situation
where that's not reasonable for your org,
I think that the--
then you are in a situation
where you need to have a
conversation with your
organization is like well since
we don't have a
tool that does this,
then you are asking me to
gain some of that skill. Like are
you making space for that? Is
that what we're going to do?
Because if it's not like
a product kind of thing,
like Connect that really
is built for you as
like you are the
one it is built for,
like you as a data scientist
to be able to deploy an API,
publish an app, all these kinds
of things. Then you're like OK,
then I need to
be able to make--
then you need like the
org needs to acknowledge
that you're asking me to
gain some of those skills.
And so I think--
so Plumber has a pretty nice
set of documentation for how to
deploy Plumber APIs. And
they have Docker containers
that are ready to go.
They have, I think,
Droplets,
like a way that you
can deploy it in a--
shoot. I forget.
what's the place that
has Droplets? I'm blanking.
The Cloud provider--
I can't remember.
- DigitalOcean.
- DigitalOcean. That's right. That's
right. So it's like, OK,
or do you need to
deploy a plumber API?
Here's how you can just
take it to DigitalOcean,
which does have fairly
good documentation
ways to get started. So
it is harder. If you're not
able to lean on a product
that's made for you as a person
who uses Python or R and wants
to deploy an API,
you then are in a situation
where your org is asking you to
do it yourself maybe or to talk
about it. So the plumber or
FastAPI,
there's documentation there.
Like how do you
actually get FastAPI
from running on your computer
to running somewhere else?
There's a lot of ways
to answer that question.
And some of them are quite easy
and built for you as a data
science user persona.
And some of them mean,
you really do have to
start going into those more ops-y
areas. I will say, if you
are a person that combines
like statistical know-how
with like ops-y know-how,
that's killer, career-wise. So I
mean, go for it. If you're
interested and
you have a little bit of
the space to start gaining those
skills like that,
that's fantastic.
Those are people who's--
like that set of skills
combo of skills is like super
valuable in the market.
When you hear about, oh,
data scientists. Oh.
I'm so annoyed. It's like
data scientists never ship,
data scientists have
terrible software engineering practices
like the coding practices. So
if you are someone who's like
no, no. I can do that.
I know how to do that. I
can learn. I have learned X.
I'm in the process
of learning Y.
Like that's
wonderful for your career.
So that's like a look
on the bright side,
kind of like silver lining
kind of situation, if
that is true for you.
- Thank you.
I'm going to jump over to
a few questions from a bit earlier.
Lisa had asked, well, she's
taking the dogs on a walk,
so I will read it.
- OK.
-
Wondering how the team finds
time to respond to questions on
Posit community and
other message boards.
Is that part of the job?
I'm so thankful and
others from Posit do it.
- Absolutely. We consider it part
of our job. So I think that--
- And Lisa's back. [INTERPOSING
VOICES] Feel
free to jump in
and say hi, Lisa.
- So I would say for the
teams, I have been on we absolutely
have considered it part--
one--
I'm just going to-- one,
one, one second.
Awesome. Thank you so much.
So absolutely,
absolutely the teams I have been
on consider it part of our job.
I do think it depends on
the maturity of the project that
you're working on.
So for example,
Hadley has told me, like when
he was first working on ggplot2,
he answered every Stack
Overflow question about ggplot2
or at least he looked
at it. He looked at it.
He made sure that--
and because it's really
valuable source of feedback.
Like it's a really
valuable source of--
it is actually good for you.
But now, ggplot2 is very mature.
And there's many people
who answer questions on Stack
Overflow about ggplot2 and so
Hadley doesn't do it anymore.
So I have set up
like RSS feeds for
Posit community questions,
for Stack Overflow
that come to a
place that I check,
like I have it going
to an RSS feed reader.
And so I--
like I literally--
every time there's a question
on Stack Overflow that's tagged
Tidymodels, I look at it.
I look at it, every single
one of them. And sometimes,
someone has beat me to
answering it. And that's fine.
Unless they answer it wrong.
And so that's totally fine.
But I just want to
make sure anyone who
comes and is having a
problem, we know what it is.
We know what it is.
It's really interesting working
on open source software from
the perspective of how do you decide
what to do and what the problems are.
Because
lots of you I think probably work
in a situation where you have data.
That's why you're hired.
There's data that exists.
And you use that data
to improve some product or to
change something. When
you're working on open source
software, just by
the nature of it,
we don't have data about usage.
We don't have data about
what most common errors are.
So you have to find
proxies for that.
And I think things like
questions on Posits community,
questions on Stack Overflow,
certainly GitHub issues.
Like these are the proxies that
we have for what problems are
people having. And so I
think it is absolutely--
yes, part of the
job of figuring
out what people's problems are.
And like I said, this,
especially applies to early
maturity projects that--
in fact incredibly valuable
data that you can use to
decide what it is that you
need to do. It definitely-- you
have to have--
you have to have a certain
mindset if you're going into this. Because
people ask--
it turns out people ask
the same question over and over.
No. But like the fact is
like either you need to--
if someone's--
if you are finding multiple
people are asking the same
question over and over,
you should fix that.
You should fix that or better
document that or make it easier
for people to not have to
ask that question anymore.
But definitely,
definitely, if you're in--
that's that part of the job
of. OK, let me go through--
here, here, here. Like all
the questions and feedback,
let me know--
let me keep in mind that
person is frustrated,
a person is having a problem.
Even if I think, oh, my
gosh, I've answered this five times.
They have not had it
answered five times.
So it's definitely a the
dynamic there is one to be
aware of, I think.
-
I think it's a good
reminder for whatever role you're in
when people keep asking you
the same question. It might be
or maybe there's a reason.
- Yeah. Right. Exactly. Exactly.
- OK. I know this time
goes by super quickly.
So I'm going to try and
rapid fire through a few questions.
But Ashley, I see you just
asked one in the chat.
Want to jump in?
- Oh, yeah. [INTERPOSING
VOICES]
- There you are.
- Ready for jumping in.
- No worries. Hi.
- Julia, love your work.
I was wondering--
I was looking into your
learner Tidymodels
from the learner package.
And I've really taken a liking
to some of the packages that
were created
especially this one.
But I know it probably hasn't
been updated in two years.
So I was wondering
if there's plans to--
if you had plans to revisit it.
- If you look
at who contributed to that,
you'll see that a lot
of work happened during one summer.
And it was because we had
an intern. An intern who came in
and really worked on that.
And I think the work--
I am really proud of the work
that we did there. And I think--
I mean if you are running
into a problem like where something
isn't working with current
versions, please do report a--
please do report. Like
a GitHub issue,
a bug somewhere.
Because we want to make
sure that continues to work.
I think those
interactive learner
things can be so effective.
And actually, I remember back to--
when I started
learning R--
R was not my first programming
language, like I came from a
lower like a C
background, like a lower.
So I had like computational
background. But I was like, OK,
I want to learn this R
thing, seems pretty cool. I actually--
the thing that I love the
most was actually Swirl, which has--
I don't even know if it's
still maintained or not. But like,
this is like 8, 10 years ago.
And I love--
what I loved about it is you
were actually in the IDE,
interactively doing stuff. And
Learner has that same feel,
like that same kind of feel
and is such an effective way.
Because really, really,
really like we learn
by doing. We learn by like
just doing, doing, doing.
So
it's so effective. So
I'm very proud of it.
So I would say that on
the Tidymodels
team, specifically, what
has been a focus, I would
say lately is more the Tidymodels
website. So if
you, for example,
like if you go to the
Tidymodels website and go over to learn,
you'll see there's quite
a lot of stuff there.
And so there's been
more emphasis on
things that
are more like content you read,
content you read versus
content that you interact with.
Partly because the
barrier is so low.
So the Tidymodels--
this Tidymodels.org was
recently moved over to being a
Quarto site. It was originally,
actually technically a blog down
site. It wasn't a blog,
but it was technically
a blog down site.
And now it's a Quarto
site.
So that makes the barrier so
low to making a new article.
It's so like
straightforward to do that.
So I would say there
are not concrete current plans
to add more things to learn
Tidymodels, which is
the learner thing. But
I think it's an interesting
question to examine. Like what
are the really effective
ways for people to
learn? The other thing
that we have done that--
oh, wait.
No. Never mind. Never
mind. Yes. So yeah,
I would say that--
I'm glad you brought that up
because I don't think we have
currently current
plans to add more.
But I think it's an
interesting question.
- And quick question,
and I only ask that one because
I love the Learner package.
I'm actually creating my own
little course using learner for
to help introduce
people to R in my field,
industrial organizational
psychology.
And actually reached out
to some people at Posit.
And I was wondering,
because right now,
it still runs only
on R Markdown.
And I think that
it would maybe--
I don't know if anyone's
looking into moving it into
Posit. It seems
like it still may--
not Posit, Quarto.
- Quarto. Yeah.
- Yeah. It seems like it's
still being maintained.
But I'm not sure if there
was any plans just because
there's a couple other people
I know that made learner courses.
And it's so it helps to
bridge that gap. Also,
and something I encourage new learners
to do is to learn in RStudio,
which is also why I love Swirl.
And that also helps the barrier
as well. So that'd be curious.
- Yeah. Yeah. I am not super
connected to that team.
So I don't have a
concrete answer.
I
yeah. I don't know.
I don't know how
possible it would be
to do that in Quarto,
but that's a really interesting
idea as well. I mean,
it's a great point--
- Actually,
I can connect with you on
LinkedIn and maybe try and find
the right person internally to
share that feedback with too.
- Yeah. That would be
great. Thank you so much.
- Javier, I see you had a
question a little bit earlier.
I'm seeing a lot of
love on that question.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Thanks, Rachel.
Yeah. Julia, I joined late
but always a fan of your
work. So just one of
the questions I had was,
like I work with a lot
of really talented,
diverse data
scientists or MLE's.
And we're writing internal
packages all the time.
Some of them
in my opinion, would be
incredible if we could open
source. But there's a sort of concern
that we work with member data,
that there's HIPAA and PHI
and PII. None of it
really making its way to packages.
But there is still that concern
that somehow there could be leakage.
In general, I've struggled
trying to convince
the top most level
folks to allow us to
open source some packages.
And I didn't know if
you had any recommendations there.
- Yeah.
That is so interesting.
And like that is such
an interesting question. Because people
like sometimes,
leadership in a company like
the risk. The risk feels too
big compared to whatever--
they're like oh, why
do you want to do that?
So I think the way. So
sometimes, you work at orgs
that really value open source,
like value contributing
to open source.
So my most immediate place I
work before here was Stack Overflow.
And Stack Overflow
had an ecosystem--
like an ethos of like,
it's normal to contribute
to open source. And because
actually, so and before
even data scientists got there,
they already had that ethos.
Like there was it's largely
like a .netCsharp
kind of shop, and like
some of the most widely used,
like logging libraries and some
of these things were made by
Stack Overflow devs.
And it was open source.
And so they already
had kind of this ethos.
And so when I showed
up, and I'm like, oh.
We're going to
do this and this.
And
like I want to open source
this piece. And they're like, yeah,
sure. So that's the
kind of situation where
people already have buy in.
But if you work in like health
care or you work in finance or
you work in something
that has higher
constraints around
like data privacy then a
tech company where everything is
kind of public anyway.
It's like all on Stack
Overflow it's like--
there
is user data that you don't
want linked but so much of it
is like, there's a public
kind of ethos. That was different.
If you don't work
in that, I think--
I think the thing
to do is to clearly
lay out why they should do
it at all. And I think--
I think there's like why
should they let you--
like let you spend time on
that? And I think one is--
one is that--
like depending,
and in this market,
maybe this is not so
compelling. But like for
recruiting, like if you are
in an org and you're like--
we work in like a field that's
viewed as a little stuffy or boring.
But you're like, no.
We can show people that
the kind of work
we do by having
an open source library or to--
and you can say like,
it can be used as a recruiting
tool to show people the kind of
tools they'll be using
with, the kind of way--
So there's like
recruiting. There is--
like I know,
pharma has just gone through
like a big kind of like--
is it like, if we all band
together and make these tools,
we can use them then in
our compliance like how we need to
report kinds of things.
- That's exactly what
I would love to do to.
- Yeah.
-
Get all the brains together
in the health care insurance space
for the greater good.
- Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I think--
I think
that there has to be a
compelling
case made. And then also, how
are you going to make sure--
what
processes are going
to be in place?
So there are reasonable
concerns about data privacy are
addressed. So I think--
it's definitely tougher
when you are in--
when you are in an
industry that has
high compliance standards.
But I do think the
pharma example is one of why--
like how it can work out,
how it can work out
to make things better actually overall
for everyone. I mean,
those people are all like
competitors. I'm
always so amazed.
I'm always so amazed at
how they collaborate.
It's pretty cool.
- Thank you. Shout
out to RN pharma--
- For real.
- It's been happening this
week too, the conference.
Julia, do you have time
for one more question?
Do you have a meeting?
- I do. I don't.
- OK. Oh, you can stay
and hang out forever?
- A little bit. Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
- Alan,
I realized I had missed a
question you asked from a bit
earlier. If you're still
on do you want to jump in?
- Yeah. I am. I got
to run also. But also
drop in my question and then
I'll listen and then I'll run.
Thanks, Julia and everybody.
I'm really curious, Julia,
if there are conscientious
decisions about things that
don't fit in Tidymodels
either because of statistical
weirdness or niche or
software engineering complexity curious
about the kinds of decision
making about things that just
don't belong and how you put
those fences up around the framework.
- Yes. So there for sure are.
And so here's where I will admit
that I actually don't have
a super strong statistical
background. My background
is physics and astronomy.
I'm not a statistician like a
lot of you. I literally have
never taken a statistics
course and through my
whole education.
So some of this--
but absolutely,
so I'm fairly self-taught when
it comes to these kinds of
things. So some of these
things that I'm about to say,
I would say we're not
necessarily my call but were
calls that I'm like,
oh, makes sense.
Yes, totally. Totally,
we're going to do this.
Like there's a specific example
in one of the Tidymodels
package that is called that is called--
that is called R sample. And
it is the package for sampling,
for sampling data. And there
is a--
let me see if I can find
it really quick. There's
a certain resampling method.
That is certainly
something you can do.
But it actually has pretty
bad characteristics.
It has pretty bad--
when it comes to
deciding like how it is
that you are going to do
resampling for a model
or something like that.
It does not
have good characteristics. I
think it's leave one out--
leave one out cross
validation. And it--
they're pretty bad. And
so we actually do have
a guardrails set up and
some of the other Tidymodels packages
that if you have
a leave one out
cross validation
set, it won't let
you tune with it.
It won't let you do with it,
because it's like pretty
much always a bad idea.
Another example is like,
when you're doing machine
learning or modeling like,
often, what you'll see in--
like you'll see like--
let's walk through
how to do this,
and then we're going to
predict using the training set.
And then we're going to--
I'm going to--
I'm going to
compute some kind of
measure, some kind of a metric
using the training set. l that
is almost certainly
going to cause--
like that's going to
be an overly optimistic result.
And so it's actually kind of
hard to do that in Tidymodels.
And we get requests
being like, I need--
I want the metrics on
the training set but that--
so definitely, there are these
guardrails.
And Tidymodels was built with
many of these guardrails in
mind to try to keep help you
to do the right thing and make it
hard to do the wrong thing.
I think it happens less
when it comes to software
like, oh, we can't do that. Like
that is like pretty much we are always
willing to try to do something
if we think it's a good idea.
So I think it happens much
more on the statistical side than
the actual software side.
Because with enough creativity
and energy, it's pretty much--
it's pretty much
possible to do anything.
- Right.
- That's a great
question though.
- Awesome. Yeah--
- The same--
like the same thing applies
like in Vetiver, like
we there's quite a lot
of guardrails in there.
Thing happens even in the
Tidyverse. It tries to keep you
from doing something that we
almost certainly is a bad idea.
- Awesome. Thank you.
Making it hard to do the
wrong thing is such a great framework
and such a good way to put
it. Thank you. This has been great.
I gotta run. Bye, everybody.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much. I
know we're a little bit over here.
But thank you so much Julia
for joining us today and sharing
your experience and everything that
you do for the community
as well. So nice to see so
many of you here today too.
- Yeah. Thank you all
so much for coming.
And thank you for having me.
- Absolutely. Have a great
rest of the day everybody. Bye.